neue erkenntnisse zum tod von finn und
moritz die zwei teenager sind nach einer
party im beschaulichen nordendorf bei
augsburg tot aufgefunden worden
im elternhaus von moritz die ermittler
stehen vor einem rätsel was passiert
sein könnte da sein 15-jähriger freund
fing bei ihm übernachtet hat wird nach
ihm gesucht die polizei kreist mit einem
hubschrauber über dem dorf ins mofa und
handy werden am bahnhof von nordendorf
gefunden doch kurz darauf die zweite
tragische entdeckung auch finden wird
tot im haus von moritz und seiner
familie gefunden nun hat die
kriminalpolizei die ermittlungen
aufgenommen hat dass er hätten sich
gerüchte über einen drogenmissbrauch die
jungs wurden nämlich zuletzt
freitagabend auf einer party gesehen und
am samstagmorgen waren sie tot vor ort
den norden darf es jetzt jörg völkerling
hallo jagd was weiße über neue details
der nebel über dieser nacht der lichtet
sich so langsam
es warten natürlich alle auf das
obduktionsergebnis von der rechtsmedizin
etwas münchen
das wird allerdings nicht die erhoffte
klärung heute bringen denn ein
rechtsmediziner hat mir erklärt die
untersuchung des blutes auf drogen
rückstände worauf offenbar auch die
aufregende situation vor ort in dem
elternhaus hingewiesen hat die dauert
länger als zwei tage was aber inzwischen
bekannt wird und was durchaus uns von
ermittlern auch bestätigt wird ist ein
sehr dramatischer verlauf dieser nacht
wir wissen ja dass moritz und finden
zunächst am nordendorfer weiter gefeiert
hatten dann in das elternhaus moritz
übernachten ging und wie mir bekannt
wurde hat offenbar finden der 15 jährige
in der nacht gegen 2 uhr am
samstagmorgen noch eine sms geschrieben
an einen kumpel sinngemäß mit den worten
scheiße tot und er muss zu dem zeitpunkt
wohl außerhalb des hauses gewesen sein
denn sein handy wurde schließlich neben
seinem mofa der nähe seines mofas am
bahnhof dass der etwa 100 meter entfernt
beim elternhaus ist gefunden
danach muss finden wieder zurück in das
haus von moritz gegangen sein wo er am
morgen in der badewanne aufgefunden
wurde
offenbar hat der vater der zunächst
seinen eigenen sohn tot fand und dann
auch die zweite leiche in baden
entdeckte ihn aber nicht sofort als finn
erkannt es gab dann einen polizeieinsatz
polizei wurde bei einer anderen familie
vorstelle ich da erklärte sich das
missverständnis und da war aber auch
schon der hubschrauber in der luft weil
man ja noch finden suchte er zu dem
zeitpunkt aber zum ist kalt und
schließlich als der hubschrauber gegen 9
uhr schon in der luft war wurde klar
dass also auch der junge in der
badewanne finden gewesen ist also mit
dem obduktionsergebnis erhofft man sich
dann endgültig klärung darüber was da
passiert sein könnte das erwartet haben
erst in zwei tagen sagt nein also die
leichen sind ja nach dem fund am samstag
nach münchen überführt worden
rechtsmediziner können dann erstmal nach
äußeren verletzungen schauen knochen
bild usw aber jetzt chemische
psychologische analysen und eine
spektrometer analyse des blutes wo man
also wellenlängen bestimmt und je nach
drogen art kann dann entsprechend eine
veränderung festgestellt werden das
dauert einfach länger als zwei tage hat
mir erst vor kurzem der oberstaatsanwalt
in augsburg gesagt dass er eigentlich
nicht damit rechnet dass heute schon
entsprechende erkenntnisse kommen
er kennt natürlich die gerüchte im ort
es ist also speed bzw mda missbrauch die
rede
man weiß auch über moritz dass er in der
vergangenheit schon mal kontakt mit der
polizei hatte er soll mal einen joint
geraucht haben mit einem freund das hat
sich rumgesprochen dann war die polizei
bei ihm zu hause also nichts großes auch
wenn moritz ein bisschen so als der
draufgänger von den beiden beschrieben
wird und auch die auffindesituation in
dem haus lässt rückschlüsse und
natürlich zu nichts nicht umsonst hat ja
die polizei schon am samstag zu einem
sehr frühen zeitpunkt ein
gewaltverbrechen und einen suizid
ziemlich kategorisch ausgeschlossen